my name is
dan friedman this is will bird and we're
going to try to entertain
entertain you today with some
relatively amazing programs and then
maybe some
really amazing programs
and um we're going to start
by doing a quick review of mindy canron
which is the language that will and i've
been working on for
a while and
we have the standard operators for those
of you who are
familiar condi and run
and fresh and equal equal and from that
we can write a little program so
let's just try something simple like run
one q
equal equal q to five
and sure enough we return the value
[Music]
are you doing that will you causing that
no okay
let's try something a little more
sophisticated let's put a condi in there
and just do something like run one queue
yeah one one queue on d um
print print equal
q to five q to six
and we run this and sure enough we get
both a oh we don't get both answers
because we forgot to ask for two values
so let's try go for
five values i was thinking
but you can go for two if you want and
sure enough we get our two answers
because that's all there are
and finally we might want to
do something a little more sophisticated
so we're going to
introduce a afresh so we'll do a room
five
q and let's put a fresh right in front
of that condi we can put it anywhere but
we'll put it there and we'll introduce
a couple variables x and y
and now we'll change that q to x
and the other q to x and then we will
vote x um yeah why not
and but let's but let's not be
shy about why let's give x5 and y
3 and x6 and
y7 no no why on that one
you know all right no y that's a good
idea sure
all right okay um i was going to do
something about q but i guess we can
wait
yeah all right let's wait all right so
we get back the
the first answer
the first answer has the property that
we it's exceeded whatever that means
and and so did the second answer so now
it's time to actually see what those are
and to do that we associate
a data structure with q so we're going
to end up
with q equal to
back quote comma x comma y
and now we see the answers are 5 3 and
6. we don't know what y is in the second
computation so we end up with underscore
dot zero which
says it's anything we want it to be
so that's pretty much the base of
mini canron and of course we haven't
done anything with recursion yet
so um before we do that though let's
talk about the other operators that are
floating around
um we have added some we
haven't really subtracted any yet so i
guess it's the way things work
so we have this operator that says um
not equal so we we spell it equal slash
equal but in print it's just the not
equal sign
through the uh equivalent sign and so
now we're saying that q cannot be 5
under any circumstances
and sure enough it says it succeeded
because we didn't do something that was
wrong and but we're reminding you that
by golly q which is underscore 0
can't be 5. so but let's let's uh let's
let it be 5 and see what happens
let's do an equal equal q to 5.
and sure enough it fails
and sure enough it fails okay so
that's basically all there is to this
equality of course things can be much
more complicated you can have
complicated expressions in there but it
doesn't matter it's still going to
basically
give you the information that you wanted
so maybe this is not going to be equal
to
oh let's try a back quote comma
x
[Music]
of course it's going to fail we're not
finished yet
okay and now we're going to say oh this
is supposed to be not equal
sorry oh not equal okay not equal x
comma y
to q let's see what it does
okay now it's saying that oh this is an
older version
um so we have uh the underscore dot zero
is the answer it succeeded again
but now suppose we do an equal equal
x we add an x to five and a y to six
again
yeah what do you think is going to
happen dan i think i know
i don't think you do
what is it gonna do it will um
well it's fresh so it should succeed
yes it should yeah okay but that's not
what i wanted
i know it isn't i wanted to now
um i think what you wanted to do is
probably
saying something yeah something like
that like yeah
that and then maybe put just a quality
constraints on x and you're saying two
of those
and then you can do like some
unification so here
uh we can unify x with five now
and of course that will fail but if we
have like the disquality constraint here
saying that they can't
be five and six
tricky stuff
all right we have three other relatively
easy
um constraints uh symbolo
which we'll we'll just do a real quick
one on that one it really is tricky
equal slash equal it's easy when you say
it and you understand what it's doing
but when you start thinking about all
the relationships that it keeps track of
you're
grateful beyond grateful that it's there
when you need it
anyway symbolo says that q has to be a
symbol
so there it is it says it's a symbol but
you can also do
things like uh number oh yeah of course
and you can also make them both you can
make a cube both a number and a symbol
let's see what happens when you do that
it fails because nothing's the number
and the symbol
right um so those are two others and
then finally we have
uh one of the great ones is called
obsento
thank you and obsento
takes a usually a variable
all right usually a variable is the
first argument
and will has now taken over
all right now i stop laughing i'll start
typing
okay so sento is basically like a tree
constraint it's saying
that the first argument to absento can't
appear anywhere
in the second argument so you can think
of these as arbitrary terms so
actually both of those could be trees or
they could be
variables or whatever so saying that
first term
can't appear anywhere in the second okay
so we've added one this is the first
time
um
um
um
so so logically this is saying that
for all x there exists
some y such that x equals y
okay so that's different if you switch
the for all and the exists
that's not true but this ordering is
correct so
basically one of the principles is that
you'll never see an eigen
variable as a top level value so it's
never going to escape find it
let's find one let's find y y is not an
eigen variable is it let's see what
happens if you do that
so sorry what do you want to do i want
the next thing
in that brush would be y
any ideas well it's going to fail
because
it's it's now become an eigen basically
by virtue of the
the equilibrium and the eigen can't be
associated with q
so down it goes okay so we're going to
be
using that a little later on today
so so the point of eigen is it lets you
prove statements
for all you know for all values so
you know it's sort of like a lexically
scoped gensim
it's like i'm going to pick some value
and i can't really tell anything about
the properties of it
and because it's an arbitrary value that
i can't really inspect
i could put it in a data structure i can
remove it from a data structure i can
compare it with itself that's true
comparing with anything else is false
basically if i can prove something about
a statement that includes that variable
that means it holds for all values
instead of just some random variables
okay
um
the quotation
um
uh
okay
oh naughty dan why'd you call it a
you're messing me up okay
[Music]
yes
yeah okay
so we can do a kandiya here actually
so if
a is equal to x the thing we're looking
for
then we have to recur on the cutter
else
uh
and then we're going to cons the a the
yeah the a on to
res and
ship them around a little bit and
i think that's it right yeah let's
run it and see what happens
actually i can go back to the old one
problem dan
um
okay
of
um
no we were first going to look at this
one
well we're okay so this is when you're
designing a state
machine
i took all these great photos in the
hotel lobby which apparently has like a
green light
so here's the overpriced but excellent
book by
sipser which is my favorite book on
formal languages it's like ridiculously
expensive but it's very very good
um yeah so here's an example
non-deterministic finite automaton it's
non-deterministic okay so first of all
if you're not familiar with
finding automaton here's an automaton
has three states one two and three
the top one is an accepting state it has
this extra circle around it and then we
have
we can also see that the first one state
one is the starting state has an arrow
coming in
and we have tray labeled transitions so
here we have
a string containing letters in the
alphabet a b
well haven't gotten that dan okay so
these transitions are telling you how to
consume
a letter at the beginning of the string
and then
brings you to a new state perhaps or in
this case back to the same state
and if you end up consuming the entire
string
and you're in one of these states well
if you're in a state that has a circle
around it then you've accepted the
string in language otherwise
you reject it this epsilon thing is
a transition a non-deterministic
transition
that you can perform without consuming
any of the string
so if you're in state one you have a
string you can either
if the string begins with the b consume
that b
and move to state two or you can
immediately jump to state three without
consuming any of the string
okay so so this epsilon transition
that's one of the hallmarks of a
non-terminus of clientometer
the other thing to notice here is that
there are two ways to get out of state
two
so we can either consume an a
and stay in state two or we can consume
an a or a b
and go to state three however
importantly
if we have a string that starts with an
a we can either stay in state two and
consume it or
consume it and go to state three so we
have a non-deterministic choice
once again and the traditional way to
implement this sort of system
is to turn the non-deterministic finite
automaton into a deterministic finite
automaton there's algorithms for that
sepsir
talks about that for example and what
you get
for that particular dfa
or sorry nfa is is this thing so we went
from three states to eight states
um and for the eight states we can see
now we have four accepting states and
it's just a much more complicated
figure but we can then do some more uh
some more translations and we can
minimize that and get this dfa that has
six states instead of a
set of eight okay but this is still more
complicated the nice thing is now we
don't have any epsilon transitions
we only have one transition coming out
of each
state every state has should have two
have a transition out of it for for each
letter in the alphabet so
uh it simplifies the implementation but
we have to go through several steps so
we have to take our non-deterministic
automaton make it deterministic probably
want to minimize it because the states
can explode
and then implement this thing which is
in some ways more complicated we have to
do all the work of translating
so it would be nice if we could just
implement this directly right as a
non-deterministic clientomaton and
as designers of systems if we're trying
to create a state machine
it's often nicer to create to to create
a
design using a non-deterministic fine
automaton then we can
massage it okay so let's go to um
[Music]
so let's go to the um
is that all we're doing is
and you may notice that all the calls
to the
state applied to arguments are what's
called entail position
so let's see what happens if we were to
trace lambda on
okay so
okay now we can run this
and you'll see that uh
let's go to the big one
notice that we come here
places
so all of these things
so so just to um clarify dan's point
accepting states have a clause that say
if the string is empty
we're going to succeed sounding for the
work okay so um
if you want to have a reject state
it's easy you just don't have a
transition that case so if you end up
with the empty string in a reject state
you just fail
you don't produce any any answers um
and then otherwise this is just tearing
apart the pairs
and doing state transitions by doing
these tail
recursive function calls
um
well it turns out that they're
equivalent and we've got some tests that
show that
yeah but uh the the the important point
here is that
this is the non-deterministic version
and we didn't have to make any changes
basically so if we
see if we can find our our picture here
um hopefully we can see that
there are similarities here so
okay so um let's see here there are
three states
so this is how to write your own
determinist non-deterministic finite
automaton
so there are three states each state is
represented
as a lambda basically it's a
tail recursive procedure these are
mutually recursive so this is state 1
this is state 2 this is state 3 at the
bottom
and state 1 is the starting state we can
see that we're starting out with q0
being returned so that's the starting
state and
in the first state we can do two
transitions we can consume a b
and go to state two or we can do a
non-deterministic
epsilon transition and just not consume
anything and jump
immediately to state three so the way
this is written is first of all since
this is an accepting state it's got a
circle around it
we have this clause to see if it's
accepting and of course
you know this is very very regular code
we could easily write a macro that
generates this stuff right
and tree rom christian murthy has has a
paper on doing exactly that for scheme
but you could do it just as easily for
many cameron
so if you have the empty string
then we're going to accept in this state
if you are
otherwise we can immediately jump to
state 3 without consuming any of the
string so this is a non-deterministic
or this is just the epsilon transition
and then finally
we can actually if we have a non-empty
string we can tear it apart
and check to see if the first thing in
the string is the symbol b
and if so then we can immediately jump
to state two
with the rest of the string so so those
are the types of transitions we have
nope
okay so yeah so this is called inforo
because this is the fourth
non-deterministic
automa in sipser's book so we can do
like a run one queue and
let's uh call n4o and give it a string
and let's give it the string so these
are a's and b's does it except a b
b except abba and
the answer is it does okay cool and we
can let it play a little bit on its own
as well
so we can just give it a variable there
and now instead of accepting strings
it's generating strings
so it accepts the empty string so what
are ten more strings
okay so it gives us back different
strings here that are all accepted so
we've turned our acceptor into
a generator and we didn't have to go
through the process of making it
deterministic and this is a trick that's
been known in prologue for a whole a
long time that you can
you can keep your finite automata
non-deterministic and then use the
non-determinism in your underlying
system
to get that ability without having to do
any of these translations
or a state explosion
okay and then let's see
so the tests to show that these are
equivalent i think this isn't a proof
but this is
some evidence that the two systems are
equivalent is that we have the
non-deterministic version in 4-0
and then we have a deterministic version
which is
d-o and this little test what it does is
it
calls mini canron with a run 200 so
we're generating 200 strings that are
accepted
by n4o and that's
on our list ants and now we're just
looping through these answers for each
of those answers what we're going to try
to do
is see if do will eventually produce
that answer
so we'll let do just produce its own
answers generate a bunch of answers and
check to see
if any of the answers match the answer
we're looking for so
sort of a generation test idiom lets us
try to check to make sure that those are
those are equivalent
okay and then there's kind of one more
thing that we could show with this and
that's
one thing you can do that's kind of
interesting is you can add
an accept or reject flag basically
so instead of just succeeding or failing
you'll actually get back accept or
reject if the
determine if the automata consumes the
entire string and ends up on some state
if it fails because there's there's no
matching transition then you'll just get
back
you won't get back that answer at all
but the cool thing with this
is that we can feed in um
uh i don't know this isn't this isn't
the uh pda
all right but i can show you for example
in this one
so this is just a very simple automata i
can show you the
that's the state machine for this one um
so the cool thing is you know i can say
give me 10
strings that result in except
but i can also say uh give me some
strings
that are rejected right and it'll give
me rejected strings
and um we actually showed this in norway
when we're at flat map
with a different approach using sort of
an interpreter-based approach
but that's kind of cool stuff
okay so the thing about the pda
is now we've added a stack
to a non-deterministic machine so we
still have the notion of epsilon
transitions once we get to a push down
automata
so we can look at
here here is our transition this is
actually
fairly straightforward the uh
the first one of course is that there's
an uh it's an epsilon transition
but it also says that if the top of the
stack so to speak
is an epsilon and you do get to pop it
but of course that's
doing nothing then you replace it
by a dollar sign it's a very clean clean
model here's a better example
here's one where we see a one
on a transition we
know there's a zero on the top of the
stack
and um we don't
do anything with the stack so we can
consume the zero in this case
and we don't push anything on the stack
right yeah so there are two things here
so
so our states are the same we have four
states here we've got q1 and q4
accepting states
start with q1 that's why it's got the
arrow and then
we have an epsilon transition means we
don't have to consume anything from the
string
and then to the right of this these are
the stack manipulations and epson on the
left means
we don't care what's on the stack we're
not look we're not popping anything
and then whatever's on the right if
that's an epsilon it means we're not
adding anything
but in this case we're pushing on a
dollar sign and
in this case here we're push or we're
popping off what it better be a zero
otherwise
does anyone recognize what this machine
does
yeah yes exactly have to be the same
length so let's see
what happens when we run it
and sure enough if you look at those
closely
the uh
so yeah it's a better thing to do
okay so here are 10 strings that are
produced and they all they all look like
the right ones
yeah so once again you know we we use
our trick of the epsilon
transitions mean that you're not
actually looking at the string
in any way so you don't have any string
manipulations accepting states we're
still representing as
having a special kandy clause saying
that the string can be empty
and otherwise we're doing
the only other thing that's new are
these stack manipulations so
in this case this epsilon transition
we're pushing the dollar sign onto the
stack we've got the old stack here
and we're pushing dollar sign on to it
we're just representing
the stack as a list and
let's see in this case we're expecting
to see a dollar sign
on the top of the stack and then we're
transitioning into
q4 without changing the string so this
is an epsilon transition
and we're pushing in the rest of the
stack okay
so um
does this cover all the things you want
to talk about
with respect to this machine
yeah i think so we could okay we'll
we'll have a couple other
uh things in the the posted code but
yeah i'm gonna get to like the good
stuff i do too
okay all right so it's quine time
so we're going to do some quines for you
but uh
maybe a little variety this time
so one second
okay okay so are you ready to run equine
yeah for those of you who have had a
chance to see
our talk at uh strains of last year
we spend a fair amount of time on quine
so we're not going to do that today but
we have one really nice one coming up
also here's the entire quine system
and we're not going to explain that
again
so let's do and but it does have um
things like car and cutter and cons
and quote which you don't normally get
in our
normal three line interpreters so here's
our
running of this and here we go let's get
it let's get equined
here we go what well yes
true evaluates to true so we're
we're all set indeed
so let's try two then oh
and false evaluates to false all right
one more shot
oh and there it is our first climb
and of course we can run as many as you
want
and stuff like that but now we're done
with coins
yes okay so do you have a second
uh i don't know if i have a second i've
got a few milliseconds
three milliseconds all right david do
you have like 20 milliseconds
i've got 20 milliseconds okay so i would
like for you to show
everyone using the same program
something um
let's just say a little different so oh
look at this
matt might has a blog post where he
wants to generate
99 ways to to to generate
programs that say i love you okay this
seems like a nice thing to do so um
so will saw that and said boy that's
easy
well exactly this is grad student pd i'm
sorry
well yeah said hey you should try this
in mini cameron so here he goes
and the result is okay
don't forget to take the oh you forgot
to take the
the length the time
and 15 milliseconds later we have 99
uh bottles of beer on the wall i don't
know
it's a very clever shell script
okay now we're really going to change uh
directions a lot
you know so here's the problem with mini
canyon like after we showed kwines
which we have to keep thanking stuart
holloway for but
uh after we showed clients is like it
was really hard to impress people
with mini cameron after that so you know
petey said okay can you do this it's
like yeah i did it in 15 milliseconds
like what else do you want me to do
and no one was impressed so i generated
a million coins
no a million i loved you a million i'm
sorry nine million coins a million i
love you programs right
and i send an email i was like hey i
generate a million i love your
programs and like no one even responded
i was like what can you do what can you
do what are you gonna do okay so we're
gonna change the
the flow a whole lot now because we may
be talking about things that you're not
familiar with
we're going to talk about something
called combinatory logic
and just a quick history of combinatory
logic and lambda calculus
in 1920
moses schernfinkel gave a talk
in 1924 his paper got published and if
those of you want to read it it's in
hagenor a book called from fraga the
girdle it's a
collection of papers fabulous collection
of papers
and then around 1928 or so curry came
into the picture
and he developed something called
commentary logic and
uh we're not going to do all the logic
stuff we're just going to do the the
computing aspects of it
and um at this point we should be
looking at um
a page full of combinators perhaps
okay and the race mullion wrote a book
called tamaka mockingbird which is for
children for young people and um
turns out chern finkel is a bird and so
he did everything in terms of birds
as a sort of thank you to him and um
this book which was actually done by a
phd student who graduated
in in the philosophy department but
uh catalan bimbo a great book on
combinatory logic
okay so can we see the list of comments
those are two good books
yeah those are two standards
okay so these are very simple rules to
read if you
know how to read them okay and that's
not necessarily follow
okay so for example let's just look at
this s combinator
on the right over here that really says
s applied to x
and then that returns a function and
then we take that function and we apply
it to
well it's y y okay and that returns
a function and then we apply that
function
uh actually that's not that's what it
means but this is what it does
that's what it means this is what it
does it produces x
z as one application
which has to return a function and then
y z which is just
the second thing and basically um
you're shifting around pieces of
information that's all you're doing when
you're writing combinators
okay just move them here move them there
and so on so look at w
for example w says if i come in with two
values i just copy one of them and leave
the others
alone so it's kind of like an equality
which of course is our bread and butter
okay so um let's just go right to some
of the examples because we are
running short um well okay
let's go to the real so how much time do
we have
minus three minutes okay yeah
all right since you've waited this long
and been good we had some problems
okay so we have this really neat program
go for it we'll go for it here's here's
kind of like the whole point of this
talk everything else kind of by the way
these things are equivalent to touring
machines so we have covered
what we promised to cover but if you
want to see touring machines in the same
style
but without gandhi but it's still
trivial in scheming the art of
programming i did that
some time ago and if you can find the
book
then you can see how we did it or you
can send me an email and i'll xerox a
couple pages for you
or photo with them with my camera
whatever's convenient
if you're watching at home you can skip
to this part of the video
but it's too late sorry
uh so all this by the way is just by
reading the book and writing
equations and thinking really hard which
will again
enough talking look here's contracto
contracto has definitions for three
combinators i
k and s so look at i for example i is
just the identity function
you apply i to some some argument you
get
the argument back this is just shorthand
for that pattern matching
and then we have k and s so i k and s
together those three combinators
that's turn complete you can express any
computable function
with those three actually you only need
s and k okay
all right so we have a very simple mini
cannon for this
program for this and in fact i will show
you how short it is
if this is the racket code for the
entire system
okay so this is the reductions for the
combinators
this is to perform a single reduction
anywhere in the term
if you have to look if you have an
application you might have to look
inside the terms to find
a single reduction and this is the
reflexive transitive closure
of the single reduction okay so sort of
like
you can imagine a little lisp
interpreter as
as allen k says the maxwell's equations
of computer science
this is an alternate take on that and
this is the relational version of it
just like we had the relational version
of the lambda calculus interval there's
our friend eigen
here's our friend eigen here's a query
what does this do
run one y huh eigen x
so this is saying that
um there exists
some combinator called y huh
such that for all x
uh y of x equals
x of y of x okay
this is the y combinator all right and
we're about to generate it
so uh here's the version that was not
using the pattern matching it's just
using the the language we showed you
uh so it's a little bit longer but it's
simpler to understand maybe
and now that we've loaded it
so this um arrow wo thing that is doing
a single
oh sorry that's the transitive closure
there so that's that's the relation we
want
and
so what i'm going to do is run one
y okay
eigenx
and we want to y of x
goes to
x of y of x okay
now this um this can take a few minutes
to generate
so i'm going to give it a little hint i
can do it without the hint but just
for time i'm going to give it a little
hint and the hint i'm going to give
is that this combinator
that there exists a version of the y
combinator that
basically is another combinator applied
to itself so here's just a little hand
it's a little guess i actually didn't
know this
existed but i took a guess and it was
right so i'm going to say y
actually looks like this it's some
combinator question mark applied to
itself
and the rest of it is just the
definition okay
so let's see if this comes back
let's see and we got a stopwatch
probably shouldn't optimize level two
uh the fun part of this if i made a typo
it will never come back
yeah now hold on okay okay okay okay
all right so we got our y commenter we
got oh sir we got our ski combinator
right that's cool cool
but the problem is this isn't scheme
code this isn't
closure code this isn't racket code we
can't run this thing right
so what we're going to do is we're going
to
call a little helper here which
is alito
now that that is a maybe not the best
ada is an operator in a land the
calculus that
allows you to take something that is
about to go into an infinite loop
and close it up so that it can't go into
an infrared
right now and that's where you end up
with what's called the z
combinator because schemes have called
by value language
and this is not designed for in the core
by value language so do you like my
beautiful y combinator
well it got a little larger but it's
still going to work
so let's see what happens now okay
now you're in scheme right i am a scheme
so you could define y as the value of
this expression
i could then do it
okay find why to be that thing
okay okay and now that you have it why
is that okay
all right now you can say now i've got
why one more thing hold
on okay here we go yeah yeah there we go
yay okay
why okay so this is our friend factorial
but why don't you do what i always do
change the f's to factorial so at least
it looks sort of like it
fine both apps okay
it kind of looks like it except there's
this free variable called lambda in the
part that looks like
factorial and you got to do something
about it so whenever you have a free
variable you don't like you just wrap a
lambda around it and everybody's happy
and do we get 120 we do
and so that really ends up our talk i
wish we had more time
we certainly have more material